oh
romantique
amical
et quelqu'un de souriant
je m'appelle alexandre guéri
je suis un homme citoyen du monde et
fondeur d'arbres accessoirement
direction l'atelier où il y en a 3 3
stagiaires qui
j'ai aujourd'hui 30 kg mais moi je suis
ici pour des raisons professionnelles et
mon fils est et reste la métropole pour
faire ses études et j'avais dit que s'il
réussissait bien il pouvait rester si ça
ne marchait pas y rentrer dans l'union
cette punition c'est tout à fait à une
carrière commerciale donc j'avais fait
un bts force de vente
à saint-andré et mais ça m'avait emmené
après donc des expériences un peu
décevante en fait où vous voyez que les
relations entre entre les gens contre
les hommes étaient bien là se basait du
coup beaucoup sur sur l'argent bonjour
sa fait alors on est dans leur atelier
de fonderie
bon ça c'est de la sir la c1
non je te cyr à base de cire d'abeille
et ça ça va nous permettre de préparer
les modèles qui seront fondues en bronze
pour faire du millage de la fonderie
faut être un peu tordu parce qu'il faut
voir tout à l'envers ou disais mais tu
peux pas vraiment un vrai métier et
c'est vrai qu'au début moi je vais
peut-être le doute mais après je me suis
dit non mais c'est un vrai métier
dans les faux donc le premier le premier
qu'on a eues ici donc c'était cela qui
nous a été légué donc pas mon maître
celui qui m'a appris le
le métier après des chutes
dans cette fonte
aubin
la démago de gros et on a des morceaux
de pièces du sinn
même si les livres c'est très bien
expliqué
il ya des schémas qu il ya des mots
c'est bien comme ça
bien écrit
on n'apprend jamais aussi bien qu'avec
l'expérience de quelqu'un il veut 30 ma
belle fille pense vraiment bon
comment les choses vont se passer lance
énormément
niveau va attendre la fonte on est
obligé
soit on est artiste sonné artisans mais
par contre sans maîtriser la matière
cette idée n'est rien ne repose sur rien
dati tous les matins dans un autre petit
rendez vous autant maintenant autour
d'un café
sanou démultiplie notre énergie est
obligé de jouer collectif c'est normal
parce que c'est on profite de l'énergie
ambiante
donc on reçoit tellement d'énergie par
les autres que du coup on dame quoi
c'est pas travail qui est doit être pris
comme une servitude
je refuse mois la servitude du travail
je reprends plutôt comme une libération
parce que c'est un métier qui m'apporte
énormément de parler les gens que je
rencontre les artistes
il allait savoir faire et la précision
il a la force pour ce métier là et il
file à son rythme c'est à dire c'est un
métier on ne fait pas forcément tout le
temps la même chose et c'est la création
donc pour moi ça serait quelque chose de
magique en fait la création même si
c'est pas de la création pure si c'est
créer des mollets fondé la pièce après
mais ça fait partie de domaine
artistique et moi je trouve ça magique
le fondeur c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
avec des techniques qui date de
plusieurs millénaires est effectivement
donc on commence à dont on commence à
pouvoir se passer avec tout ce qui
impressionne 3d etc
mais ceci dit donc sont ils un savoir
faire savoir vivre aussi autour de son
métier qui a quelque chose de
d'universel
pour ça on l'a fait avec richard dans
l'atelier donc ça c'est une pièce en
aluminium dont qui a été fait donc ça
prouve un profil humain donc avec des
avec des canettes avec qui sont insérés
voilà donc c'est une évocation un petit
peu la société de consommation
il ya une alchimie c'est un métier qui
recèle de la chimie donc tout ce qui se
transforme dans une fonderie
c'est quelque chose qui transforme
l'homme merci à toi